hey critic what are you looking at my
next movie review called blood rain
pretty bad I take it it's an moveable
movie moveable arnaz film so bad they
caused people to bash their heads in
with a sledgehammer uh-huh after jumping
out of a plane yup after blowing up an
airport that's right after crashing a
car filled with explosives doused in
gasoline while shooting a semi-automatic
while going into oncoming traffic while
singing I'm a Yankee Doodle Dandy twice
well I can see why you don't want to
review it it's not the only reason you
see whenever I do an over Bowl movie
there's a tradition tradition it's a
long story I can take care of it myself
hello and welcome to atop the fourth
wall or bad comics bird sometimes a
comic comes along hungry just capped
it's time
of course there was a final fantasy
anime and of course it sucked but even
after the first episode
right you guys are so dramatic
with a bowl the most faithful movie
adapter a video games since the
directing team behind Super Mario
Brothers returns with what many consider
his crowning achievement of shit blood
rain the movie based on the classic
video game and buy based I mean more
gangbang and mutilated than a game of
Thrones character once again
demonstrates both talent if you can call
it that for cutting more corners than a
paper snowflake and if you thought
twilight was the worst to service to
vampires the world has ever known
it is but this one's pretty bad too so
let's not waste any time this year on
that deck critic oh we have something we
have to address first the elephant in
the room which of course is him but what
I do hope you know exactly what you did
it happened a few years ago the drama
that was caused everything that happened
on Twitter on Facebook on everything
like that the betrayal of everything
that we stand for roll the clip you
never went to Castleton I dropped out
okay this is blood rain dude do we have
to censor the lettering those two O's
are looking pretty phallic hey if the
aliens local could get away with an AI
giant I think we can let that pass
wonder if the word is special is code
for blackmail I just assumed Oh
civilians career is blackmail
we open up in actually I don't know they
never give a location or a time period
so that's already two of the basic five
essential story elements ignored now
let's just throw Y in there too as I'm
sure most of this film will ignore that
as we see a team of Wanderers led by
Michael Madsen and his lion maiden
mullet the main thing I noticed
throughout this movie is it just seems
like Michael Madsen is drunk off his ass
through the entire film shoot seriously
just look so drunken miserable like they
had to send a grip to his trailer and
clean him up in a hurry slap that ratty
ass wig on his head and maybe get a few
usable takes out of him how long do you
think it will take to get there you must
go back to brimstar this is what I've
decided to do monastery has been
attacked and the eye is gone you can
almost sense the grip just off camera
with a Long Island iced tea waiting for
the scene to end and into shamble over
and take another drink what do you have
for us I think I may have found
something of interest but one of them
notices that the person next to him has
little to reflect on
I like you brimstone people you never
make a mess of the place what have you
heard what might only be the top moving
on I guess one even batted an eye is
this like an everyday thing
Wendy killing a vampire become
yesterday's news yeah I don't care where
or when you are and again neither does
uber ball but killing a vampire will
never be a boring thing guys guys holy
shit you won't believe it I just killed
a vampire
was it a Nazi vampire well technically
no but I'll police cinema snob everybody
knows that nazi vampires are all the
rage now yeah what you did is like the
Bing search engine of vampire killings
but he killed a family of six
go away cinema snob I can't even stand
to look at you okay I guess I can drop
its clothes off at the goodwill or
something you do that we don't see a
carnival we're a half human half vampire
named Rain played by Christina Logan is
dragged out as a sideshow attraction so
Barry
wait a minute was that holy water nope
then how the hell did it burn her Oh
Linkara this is the Stephanie Meyer age
of vampires you can make up anything if
you want to say water hurts them even
though it's not blessed it's okay now
yeah if you want to say they in no way
can fly turning the bats or do most of
the cool things vampires do that's okay
now - oh I see
and if people travel for miles to see
one as an attraction hit nobody turns
their head if one is stabbed and
violently decomposes in front of their
eyes it's totally okay now I know and
knowing makes it even more confusing but
one of the other attractions the amazing
candle slicer takes a liking to rain and
dreams of living in a better world with
her my uncle he's a sailor and he once
told me of a place where people play all
day and the trees grow fruits in every
color of the rainbow and the sunsets set
the whole sky on fire yeah tons of
popcorn there there's cotton candy
mountains of it and chocolate milk
the Bolton's have a field of alpha for
the rabbit without war and traffic
accidents for the sake of the human
being doesn't hit some wonderful rain we
then cut to her is gaping wait when did
that happen
oh I guess she was just dreaming does
she always dream in Photoshop smears
yeah I'd need to be drunk to get through
this movie to wait a minute now she's
back in the field what the hell's going
on it's a dream a flashback what Frank
Miller's time codes are more fluent than
this the three hundreds come across the
carnival where rain was and discovers
it's burnt to the ground this is the
work of a young vampire we have work to
do um thank you for chopping off the
heads of our dead people and burning
their bodies didn't mean to bite me and
stamping our performers I'm sorry have
you been helped
seriously did these people ever react to
anything why does nobody care that these
wackos are chopping up their dead and
living cast members just another fad
gone passe I guess guys guys I just
decapitated 20 corpses and stabbed an
injured woman through the chest no
reason really I'm just kind of sick were
they ninja decap dead corpses I didn't
ask what their martial arts background
was how snob everyone knows if there's
any decapitated quarters we're talking
about its name to decapitate the corpses
does this guy ever wake up they sneak
without thought man but I have a thirst
for blood that can't be quenched away
with you snob you become more dated with
every passing view why won't someone
help me
meanwhile at Castle Brown filter we see
Billy Zane dictating a letter to his
daughter although we've had our
differences in the past
I beseech you now to put away old
grudges for the good of humanity and
together we will stop this madness and
bring peace to these lands your beloved
father etc etc and if you have any
information about how to get this dead
skunk off my head it would be most
appreciated what do you think a very
compelling argument master he was such a
sucker bottom-line Lovejoy fight huh his
daughter in this movie is played by
Michelle Rodriguez and if you couldn't
tell by your unbelievable resemblance to
him surely you could tell by her pitch
perfect completely unmistakable British
accent will you be opening up the gates
to the throne grave important you should
not travel with we're growing weak I
seek to feel secure be sure this message
arrives ah it's good to know those years
of the Dick Van Dyke School of accents
paid off you would secure the entrance
until I return well I have to be moving
along dear Lord Mayor's ago stopped-up
chimney
we then see rain enter a village where
she comes across a female vampire
hitting on a man which clearly rained
hate says she would find her attractive
and beckons her to come forward
bow-chicka-wow-wow but a fortune-teller
sees the bit and run and decides for
really no reason whatsoever to tell her
the future must believe that you're kind
of merely legends part vampire part
human generally they're exterminated
you've hidden well yes you've been
displayed in front of dozens of people
and killed off an entire carnival
single-handedly you're better than Solid
Snake there was a moon kagan cake it's
not a man he's a vampire and you are his
creation he killed my mother
damn tears are rarely a product of a
happy union between a vampire and a
human you lie so you mean your vampire
father killing your mother was a happy
Union boy somebody's in denial
the father is even no he just likes to
drink the blood of Catholic nuns he was
mean to your mother what man wouldn't
dissin bound his wife for spilling the
sugar you like to watch in the porn
style that is a lie it is so obviously
scripted who can be as stupid as chun-li
you are a fraud I thought it's getting
worse I just bit the neck of a
prostitute no one seems to notice
was it a zombie prostitute what the hell
is wrong with everyone
meanwhile at Hogwarts we see Ben
Kingsley presumably paying off an LED TV
as rains evil father
he's just been told that rain is off to
get a magic eye
sure which is said to help get his
attention
oh look a sailboat kill him let her find
the eye Oleta try then kill her
something you'll notice very quickly is
that Kingsley scenes are phenomenally
short some barely even reach a minute
they're so short I think he literally
charged by the second you could pretty
much sum up every scene with are you
evil yep just checking
rain then makes her way to the monastery
where the eye is said to be hidden she
finds a secret location which lead her
to a door guarded by an overcooked
fester Addams look out you nearly hit
the camera good
is this really the best security they
could get just because he looks like a
melting candle a Steve Austin doesn't
mean his whack-a-mole method holds any
water next chances a booby-trapped room
that makes Indiana Jones look like a
true life drama the gutter security
system from itchy and scratchy
Yeah right I think we all know what
happened to her hmm what the dangerous
water is suddenly released yeah that's
still thing and she absorbs the power of
the eye which makes her immune to it
activating the water trap for the device
that makes you immune to the water trap
hey here's an obvious question what if
the person getting the I wasn't a
vampire I mean okay the whole vampires
melt and water thing is stupid already
but what if it wasn't a vampire that got
it though well it was just a normal guy
with the water really be that big a
threat you have stolen the forbidden
treasure now face the ultimate torture
huh that's mildly annoying can't do my
pips but all the water all the buzz saws
that all the giant guards are no match
for their final defense a polite man who
nicely asked her to come with him I
suggest you follow me it seems that you
absorbed the eye why do you protect it
because the eyeholes powers why do you
think more than the longer burns you
still wondering how it hurts or to begin
with the human body is 60% water and
blood is 80% water how the hell another
one Karl and Cara you're think too hard
about just let it go but but then just
dumb in a dog-cart just keep telling
yourself it's a bowl man it's with a
bowl mmm it's over bull crap they all
belong to a long dead vampire
he discovered the metals to defy those
elements that destroy vampires so it's
explained that the eye and three other
separated body parts belong to a vampire
who tried to perfect their weaknesses
and that if the body parts were all
brought back together it would make the
most powerful vampire ever one if he
managed to pull this off then how did he
ever die - if they're so powerful why
didn't they just destroy the damn things
to begin with this movie is driving me
crazy
come on the car you got to calm down and
I remember we were talking about
moveable I now - yeah that did make you
feel better actually Oh
- carvings but Kagan's men attack and
probably the bloodiest end gets somehow
not actually gory fight scene in movie
history the makeup is so fake and poorly
photographed that it's barely worth the
r-rating look at this guy he's cutting
habits you can clearly see his legs
standing up well you don't know maybe
Wallace made him a pair of extra legs
like in the wrong trousers how do these
guys don't even look that pain to be
stabbed they just looked kind of annoyed
like they've been in the makeup chair
for eight hours and just wants his crap
off
oh I guess
where's the I perhaps killing you will
get you to answer my question
rain gets knocked out but that's a
little consequence as we have more
important things to focus on like hey
it's been ten minutes time for another
five-second Ben Kingsley cameo come
closer
don't be afraid yeah all he's gonna do
is rip open your neck and feet on your
insides I can see why rain thought her
mother and him had a happy union and
just when you think this is the most
pointless celebrity cameo take a look at
who they got to play the owner of the
vampire feeding house why do you come
here and someone Palace with your stench
is that meatloaf yep
wearing a nineteenth-century powdered
wig it surrounded by whores and giving a
performance more over the top at kabuki
pole-vaulter yeah the mightest of all
vampires
oh my god this is comedy overload we
need time to get all the jokes together
pen paper we'll be right back we just
need time to get all of these jokes out
and organized
okay so we've had plenty of time to put
together our meatloaf jar so let's shake
this up and see what we can catch
ladies and gentlemen Wolfgang Amadeus
meatloaf how is it he managed to find a
roll even more demeaning than bitch-tits
suddenly his role in spice world is
looking like a step up just because you
did wear women's clothing in Rocky
Horror doesn't mean you have a perfectly
good excuse to win here we know you're
prostituting yourself to be in this
movie but you didn't have to make it
quite so obvious it's midnight at the
lost and pray to God not found this
movie sucks who's a lot more imagination
come on we were reaching the end of the
break I panicked actually they were just
buying the clothes it just so happens
meatloaf came with them meatloaf a day
keeps the subtlety away they still liked
this movie better than to catch a Yeti
and finally I would do anything for ball
but I will not
yeah
how'd you get in here wait but three
little weeks from school ah we break in
and try to bust her out they of course
have to fight off some dangerous foes
let's turn you around here buddy there
you go
they cut up the guards and break open
the window to make Meat Loaf face
everything under the Sun oh how nice he
did the Colossus yell before he died so
rain explains her backstory which was
already explained about how Kagan broke
in and killed her mother
hey come on I'm Gandhi don't you wanna
say you've got with Gandhi one of the
hunters in particular named Sebastian
takes sympathy on her as his parents
were killed - my mother was killed
before my own eyes my mother and father
were both killed well that's enough for
me to start banging wait a minute what
yep the fact that they both have dead
parents is reason enough to apparently
make vampire Whoopie how much screen
time have they shared together well
let's see sir ticket you two a minute
one minute together and they're fucking
in a cage like horny Canaries yeah where
the hell did that come from that makes
no friggin sense
oh please who hasn't just met a person
in jail talk for only a minute confesses
parents are dead and home to each
other's brains out in the middle of a
half-open prison door I'm speaking
hypothetically so as they train her to
be a member of the brimstone warriors
Billy Zane gets word of his daughter's
actions hey here's a fun game count how
many times Billy Zane blinks in every
scene this land has become unsettled
doors to the future must be held in the
hand a vampire perfected there's an
invitation that's nothing
count how many times Michael Madsen
pauses in between every single line
you're an important part of the
brimstone society cause your work cause
defending the fortress cause it's
essential eyes who are struggling
survival ours and no one ours has ever
questioned that oh you are our leader I
mean as a fighter
cause I will take Sebastian cause if it
pleases you
Jesus you're making William Shatner look
like the Micro Machines guy as our
heroes go to get weapons for battle
nothing but the best plastic non Sharp
swords Toys R Us goodbye who would use
plastic swords in the middle of a battle
hmm let's get my answer we seen
Rodriguez has betrayed her clan it leads
Kagan's army into their village bogging
for freedom
we'll leave your children motherless as
a brimstone martyr yes oh my bad
I thought we were doing it slow-mo scene
maybe I should pull that out at regular
speed rain goes after Rodriguez alone
and defeats her while finding the other
magic talisman she finally rise to
confront Kagan and what's her ingenious
plan to get in without getting yourself
captured take up getting herself
captured feel like she missed a step
there but it's okay because mullet won
and mullet too haven't even better plan
to get in without getting themselves
captured getting themselves captured has
the film just given up now gonna try
that hard to begin with so rains gonna
be sacrificed with the talisman to make
Kagan the strongest vampire in the world
or some shit like that honestly if you
still care you should up the dosage or
whatever you're taking a dump ta dab it
how dare you strike my daughter I'm
about to kill so this is when Michael
Madsen does the weakest and stupidest
attempt at the guard sick man escape
routine I've ever seen in my life
role my companion is gone I don't know
what's become of him so the guy just
walks in there looking for the magic
disappearing prisoner and of course he
gets knocked out this delivery is so bad
I can't even tell if it's done
intentionally badly or not it's amazing
how could anyone possibly believe a lie
so poorly delivered my companion is gone
I don't know what's become of him guard
these pretzels are making me thirsty I
don't know how I could have gotten so
hungry
sure enough the two guys that got
captured taking on all the castle guards
so suddenly have no problem taking on
the exact same guards again hey two of a
bull I'm surprised they cared enough to
do it right in the first place well I
guess Matson felt the same he gets
captured killed and following the theme
of the movie couldn't give a rat's ass
my god man you're being stabbed don't
you care
it's like he's barely awake what would
it take to get an actual emotion out of
this guy
rashon after sebastian gets stabbed as
well it's down to rain and kagan to duke
it out in a sword fight with more
dialogue than Monkey Island fencing this
strong rain but not skilled enough I
would choose death you're interfering
the fade vampire shall rule the earth as
if your interests are no I am rubber you
are glue sticks and stones may break my
bones I never get into the prison I'm
just saying it never happened the
centuries we've been cursed the shadows
slaughter by the fearful you condemned
me the day you raped my mother
ungrateful bitch to shade ungrateful for
what fuck you
rain finally defeats him and the battle
is won yay
this role still had more dignity than
the Mandarin please please you don't
have to leave me it's my time
but we had so much dead parents jailed
or fucking and then in a very bizarre
ending even for who Vibol reign takes
the throne and thinks of all the times
blood has been spilt in the movie
it does make me realize how many people
apparently had red hoses buried in their
bodies
yes we have a minimum one minute for
romantic chemistry a whopping couple of
seconds for most of the villains
establishments and yet over four minutes
of replaying all of the film's goriest
moments in slow-mo that we already saw
before at least he has his priorities
straight
we hope you see now why you should never
leave your kids around movable as if
this movie wasn't proof enough
if the Syfy movie the week is too good
for you that Hoover Bowl is the one for
you everybody else knows that his movies
fight it and this one is no exception
his characters are flat his writing
ridiculous and his stories never make
any semblance of sense and the fact that
it has little to nothing to do with the
original source material makes it one of
the most laughably bad adaptations ever
what else can you say but this movie
sucks well thank you guys so much with
helping me for another evil bull review
no problem my pleasure okay fine
why don't you just fly away I could only
do it once see was that so bad
no it was worse well what are you gonna
do now I am just gonna sit here and
stare forward thinking about the review
I just watched hoping I can trick people
into thinking I'm more artsy than I
really am all right whatever does it for
you
wait a minute Oh remember doing that
like I said critic once a stooge always
a stooge yeah you
you
my companion is God I don't know what's
become of him